whoa whoa whoa before we start the show
i want to remind you the tour ain't over
yet gang nope to keep it moving towards
going all the way through the year you
got a few more chances to see us come
check us out yeah december 14th 15th and
16th we're going to be in uh the funny
bone in hartford connecticut and then
the funny bone in albany new york and
then even further north the funny bone
in syracuse new york get your tickets
the last shows of the year it's gonna be
a good one doing and the techies are
moving too so get on it welcome to
another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
[Music]
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage sure it is a little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
i find they have the girl to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here in
auntie's basement the basement is
completely flooded is it from the rain
yes it is sure it's completely
flooded down here her insurance
shmurpishes and we'll be making a claim
to our her insurance carrier sure right
you see an adjuster an adjuster poking
around play [ __ ] ball yeah dump some
water on your shoes or something like
that
yeah go stand in a bathtub make it look
like there's water downstairs very
tragic down here
a lot of uh roll up your pants you know
play along
take the shoes off a lot of pain and
suffer oh my neck god damn it
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me the ceo of are you garbage
international businessman world-renowned
pop star
okay huge in south korea i'll take that
huge doing uh
you're featuring on uh billy eilish's
new album or yeah you're involved in the
taylor swift tapes whatever it's called
sure kj
kevin
hey what's up gang happy to be here as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on itunes even though that
don't [ __ ] matter anymore uh full
video available on youtube and as you
know those numbers are true
subscribe hit the button and i would
like to take a minute just sit right
there and tell you how i became the
prince of patreon.com are you garbage
check it out folks you get bonus content
every week listen let's break it down
real quick five dollar level you get a
bonus ayg 10 level you get a bonus ayg
and a hard feelings 20 level you get all
that plus a monthly live stream that we
do with the gang that's a real [ __ ]
hoot talk about personal service and
then we got [ __ ] we got a bunch of
[ __ ] on we got the cribs videos of my
childhood house your childhood
we got some live show clips up there we
got [ __ ] whole nines on there when we
demo ride and when we get to 2800
patreons taking the boys down out of
disney world that's right maybe do a gig
down there in florida chase some
alligators do a gig down there in
florida pick up a one night or two yeah
what the beaks baby you know what i mean
you gotta [ __ ] cover travel kippy's
djing in miami
dj kj
and how about a nice quick shout out to
our producer extraordinaire the magic
man makes us all look good we love them
you love them give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes what up
bro i have a so i have a confession to
make about the walt disney trip oh boy i
said i had never been turns out i have
been as like a five-year-old apparently
i got lost spent the whole time crying i
don't remember [ __ ] another family found
you and took you geez
last name santinelli yeah oh man that
big old donga is
i knew you were dying good kid dying
t-bone stinks dude you blocked that out
what kind of a loser talk about weak
childhood trauma
you blocked that out i mean we can all
get hit by buses and stuff i'll tell you
man
that's crazy five you're you know what's
going on five you got a checking account
i was i was cranking bernie's at five
what are we doing here you got lost in
disney world what a loser yeah that's no
good
somebody got to get down there
apparently there's a photo of me crying
on the teacups
that was from spring break but still
kid was a late bloomer what do you want
he had a hookah necklace on or whatever
the [ __ ] those things are yeah
man you're out to lunch
those things stink
i hated those things from jump yeah but
i wanted to say real quick what'd you
want to say there big man i think it's
uh do we i mentioned taylor swift how
badass is is that bird she's i don't
know a whole bunch of but she's from
like my hometown area she's [ __ ]
redoing all of her albums because some
bozo has her masters yeah so she's
[ __ ] redoing them that's a [ __ ] who i
think one of our friends is in bed with
so let's not call him a bozo public
we got some pretty powerful friends
nowadays we gotta keep our mention who
we're talking about
yeah i mean dude when the cameras aren't
running i'll trash anybody with i'll try
shooting me i'll trash my [ __ ] mother
thumb bro well it's pretty cool she's
pretty tough to just yeah i like that
[ __ ] she was like [ __ ] you i'm kind of
just doing this yeah and um can we just
start a nice run of applause real quick
the shirt has come back ladies and
gentlemen the palm tree shirt look at
that
would you have to run into the car
i wore this shirt specifically today for
one reason it was the only thing clean
two reasons only thing without barbecue
sauce on it three reasons
the craziest part of that shirt is those
trees started out as bushes
there's a couple dying on the back
they cleared it out for new development
putting in a golf course on my uh on my
midriff
um is it mid-rib or mid-drift
are we talking what are we talking about
fast and furious it's [ __ ]
you're mid-drift
isn't it mid-drift i don't know i think
it is
i remember in school oh man we had a
real we had a real creepy assistant
principal who would always be like
yelling at the girls for what they were
wearing looking back you're like this
was he always had a huge bottle of
jergens in his office too that we used
to make fun of they used to [ __ ]
you know you're wrong on you're wrong
twice what is it it's not either it's
mid-riff you made a riff
yeah like i [ __ ] up the show when you
guys are mid-range
you call it a t-bone shirt
hey your t-bone's showing
your t-bone's connected to your
anywho anywho i wore this shirt for one
reason and one reason only
this is the last time i'll be wearing
this shirt
officially
last time you heard it here we want to
put a couple of side bets on this t-bone
can i come up in the cans a little bit
well here's why yeah i'm gonna give it
away wow if anybody wants it i will get
it dry cleaned and i will mail it to you
okay
couple of photographs
so if anybody's kidding if anybody has a
wave runner they need a winterize
hit up the big man he's got you covered
he got an old car sitting in the
driveway
i'm worried about hail damage this
winter
if anybody wants it reach out and i'll
send it to you okay how about that
that's great that way be home because i
know the only way that i won't wear this
shirt as if someone else has this if if
somebody gets you have some weird
emotional connection to that shirt i've
it's insane i've pulled this out of the
trash four times because my girlfriend
is throwing it out yeah what does that
poor woman think that's crazy
okay you're not having fun with this
oh man
i just struck a chord with the big man
dude you sealed up like a clam
yikes this is actually great for us
because now we're number one in customer
service and grossest giveaways
we gross giveaways he's got he's he's
got a pair of stained undies too if you
want them
i got a sock with a hole with a towel
missing
anyway that's good that's what i'm going
to do i'm going to give it away
i'll pay the postage i'll pay everything
got to try it clean i'll send it to you
can do whatever you can burn it [ __ ]
make uh i don't know pillowcases how is
it what is it if you what's that what's
the giveaway
i'm giving you my shirt yeah but what if
more than what if three hit me up
that's it but what if three people say
they want it you gotta do some sort of
raffle bidding war i don't want money
uh i just need two first class tickets
to france please
[Laughter]
second class is fine
we'll get into that in a second uncle
hang through a [ __ ] hail mary
um
i don't know what do you think i never
thought about it to be honest it's the
most disgusting thing i've ever heard in
my life
i mean the amount of skin cells that are
on that i'm getting a dry clean i'll get
it martinized
whatever that is
that's like doubles martinelli's and
it's [ __ ] apple juice you bozo shut
up just you dunking it in apple juice
i got it mossed
were you a moths family growing up i
mean i don't think the demand will be
that high
so let's see if anybody actually hits me
up i don't know that shirt is very
divisive in the comments a lot of the
other people like they're in it or
people genuinely like i don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on this thing's here
again why if it was a black t-shirt
nobody would even know the difference
i know but it's not
right so what's i mean i i wear this
t-shirt as much as anybody else wears
their favorite t-shirt that is proper
insane how is that insane foley you wear
that you wear that more than anything
i've ever seen anybody wear anything
ever i i can prove you're wrong right
here what is mine and kippy's favorite
t-shirts yes yours is the [ __ ]
degenerator t-shirt or whatever that is
no he's wearing one of his other bozo
t-shirts pop he's wearing a pup t-shirt
and i don't even i don't know how many
of those you got i got about 12 of them
really yeah yeah like you can afford 12
t-shirts
start calling you bezos yeah um
cool i'll give it away a great see what
happens okay now to finally give a
number one to ten
i'm thinking of a venmo one 1-50 who
wants it now to some financial news sure
i'm all jammed up i know cause you stink
i stink
so i wanted to uh let you know
if you asked me for money i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna drop cash i'm not
gonna ask you for money i just asked
navy federal for money you went out for
a loan went out for a loan dude [ __ ]
business suit on briefcase
had my nephew [ __ ] pretend like he
was my chauffeur like in the catchy if
you can oh my god
the admiral of navy federal is going to
open the door for your uncle
i just called him up and what'd they say
who are you are you the guy that owes us
20 g's currently
under review
that's never good no it's never good i
can check right now to see
what do you need money for i just want
to have a little bit of a cushion to
make sure everything's kosher
nothing yet
words still out they're probably at
lunch probably out there on the high
seas
er
the fat man needs a loan i feel like
you're like i came up with the best move
i got the best move for the trip to
france i applied for political asylum
[Laughter]
i'm a refugee
[Laughter]
so this is a marriott hotel what
but yes if i did run out of a check in a
french cafe i would head straight to
these
good luck trying to get that [ __ ] get
get those those embassies a couple of
[ __ ] marines those embassies don't
let you run up on them they send a
couple of warning shots at the ground
up you can't just waltz into one i'm an
american citizen yeah wow look at the
size you'd be like all right he's one of
us little man
goddamn is that the hawaiian print
t-shirt
how you feeling boys
cup of coffee
get the [ __ ] out of here that's if you
don't think that that's not in the back
of my mind i already got the route
from [ __ ] the hotel to the to the
embassy over there
ship pops off okay
good i'm glad
ready to make a [ __ ] move okay all
right right easy big man i believe you
what are you saying i won't be able to
you're gonna get stuck in a cab or
something something's gonna happen
stuck in a cab physically stuck that's
little tiny cars over there
you'll be in the back
stock they have those little euro cabs
over there
rear yeah i mean that's a cop but yeah
they got them too you should you should
born supremacy every time you walk into
a every time you walk into a restaurant
look at your girlfriend be like i don't
know who i am but i know there's 15
croissants over there and i'm going to
be the first guy to eat
[Laughter]
beating the [ __ ] out of a waiter with a
phone book listen i don't know who i am
or who you are but i need five grand go
ah you stink
i can't wait to hear this my girl gets
kidnapped over there i don't know who
you are what you want i don't have any
money
and you can keep her i never really
liked her to begin with
[Laughter]
if you could ask her what the netflix
password is
that would be big for me
talk about a win-win huh boys
we can work together on this you know
[Laughter]
i can give you all our do's and don'ts
she loves it when you come home late
okay
oh that's good that's some good stuff
good stuff it's fun stuff we're having
fun over here over here yeah on a
youtube
um
all right what do you say we get into
some questions i would like to answer
some some questions from the patreon and
it is a family it's a family episode
it's a family when you're here
your family when you're here we gotta
co-opt that somehow right when you're
here your family who does that don't
tell me when you're here you're family
that wendy's
don't tell me for you it is
when you're here your family olive
garden there you go yeah i've been doing
olive garden in a long time let's go my
aunt used to take when i was in college
she used to take me out to an olive
garden like once every couple of months
he's like let's do dinner i'm like all
right i felt like
that was like a one at one point in my
life that was a nice restaurant we were
like i was like damn olive garden here's
something here's the thing with those
corporate establishments sure they take
a lot of heat they know their way around
their dishes as we i've said this in the
past okay
the training that a server bartender
um front of house back of house staff
receives in those places top notch is
top it's it's it's it's industry
standard it really is steps of service
this that and the other thing now that
all goes to [ __ ] the first weekend you
know what i mean when you go when you
when you find the perk guy at work you
know i mean you start banging some
bartender you're going out with the
squad sure everyone's [ __ ] slacking
on their side work but when you you go
through like a week of training they
know what they're doing sure and i'll
further say this what will you say all
right
a lot of those things are regional are
they in the city are they in the suburbs
but do you find an olive garden in a
nice suburb
with good kids working there
that's a [ __ ] top shelf meal i'm
telling you one of the best meals i had
was that fridays out in like altoona
pennsylvania
daniel's burger god damn i don't know if
the chef was just like in the [ __ ]
zone that day or whatever but he was
cooking up good good batch of meth came
here yeah he was [ __ ]
he was swinging for the fight too
that was his championship game dude chef
is outrageous
his first name chef dude
the crispy i can still visualize the
crispiness
on the on that [ __ ] appetizer sampler
we split yeah those mozzarella they
should be catering weddings with those
things those appetizer samplers at
fridays yeah ain't nothing to shake a
[ __ ] mozzarella stick at all
all right guys so this is a family
episode as you know when you join the
patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air we get a [ __ ] ton of
requests dms emails the whole nine yards
is just the best way to do it patreon
gets the first crack eater uh this one's
kind of in the same vein this is from
tim hey guys first time long time i love
that that they love it they're co-opting
that first time
um
is this garbage when you tell somebody
you went to a bar like a local bar i
guess whatever and they ask who was
working tonight like if you're like a
real when i was like a local at
we was the rich borough pub was like the
local [ __ ]
watering hole bunch of degenerates in
that place now when were you going there
when when when were you living at home
for an extended period of time i had a
townhouse i me and my buddy at a town
house in bucks when i first met you
uh no i met you probably a little bit
before that but you were i met you in
college when i was in college and when i
graduated college i moved back to bucks
county and me and my buddy got a
townhouse
did you started doing comedy yet i had
done it a little bit in college
and then i bombed that one time when you
really remember we've talked about it
you were like hey listen i want to hear
you say it again
because i need you you got to go up
there you got to close out strong and i
went up
and i saw the disappointment in your
face from just my [ __ ]
like like we were at the apollo or
something meanwhile there was there was
seven guys on [ __ ] quaaludes in the
front row
he gave me that they were industry
though i told you he gave me that same
speech at the raven yeah johnny
hollywood oh i'm sorry i want people to
do good sorry i'm a positive influence
around my peers oh is that what you
think you are walking around here you
think i'm a couple person everybody
i believe the direct quote was look kid
this guy stinks i'm gonna need a home
run
[Laughter]
and you struck out so
mid-riff he struck out by the way oh man
gang this podcast is brought to you by
better help if you have something that
uh that is standing in your way of your
happiness uh i'm in therapy uh
kippy's dabbled in therapy yes it's very
game changer very important mental
health is is very important and better
help makes it easy they make it safe
there's no embarrassment you can get a
certified counselor from the privacy of
your own home and we highly recommend it
yeah it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help line it's professional therapy
done securely and safely online broad
range of expertise available uh if
something might not be locally available
to you if you live in a small town
certain area might not be available can
i say this real quick you can say it pal
it was very difficult to find a
therapist in i'm in new york we're in
new york new york city very difficult to
find a therapist that um
you know was trained and and what what i
needed uh-huh you know what i mean i
can't imagine what it's like you know
around the rest of the country so better
help if they can offer that that is
unbelievable yeah you can log into your
account anytime send a message to your
therapist you'll get a timely thought
timely and thoughtful response plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions uh so you won't ever have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room as
you do with traditional therapy which is
always a headache um special offer for
are you garbage listeners you get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage uh that's betterhelp h
betterhelp b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash garbage you'll get 10 of
your first month do it yeah gang let's
talk about skylight
don't know what it is know what it is
what is it absolutely fantastic it's a
frame that you can upload pictures to
online and it does a nice little uh
what's it called a montage montage very
nice we got it for my cousins um it was
their anniversary a lot of people
couldn't be there it was during during
covington sure couldn't be there
everybody uploaded their favorite
memories and they got to sit there and
watch it it's actually a fantastic gift
yeah skylight frames is a perfect gift
and then it's the holiday season get
your mom yeah father your sister they
eat it up denise is the nephews they
love it they don't even need us to be
doing this at delby skylights at every
christmas party every holiday party this
year i guarantee yeah it's a photo frame
you can update instantly by email from
anywhere
it's great to feel close with those that
you love even when you're separated due
to these crazy times that we're in
um skylight frames has a gorgeous 10
inch touchscreen you can swipe through
the photos uh even tap the person you
like who sent the photo 100 satisfaction
guaranteed if you don't love your
skylight they'll offer you a full refund
look at that you can pre-load it with
your favorite photos um and make it a
personalized gift for somebody they sent
us one i got it set up in the living
room it's fantastic special offer for
are you garbage listeners you get ten
dollars off your purchase
of a skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com and enter code garbage
that's right you get ten dollars off
your purchase you got a skylight frame
just go to skyla
skylightframe.com and our code garbage
at skylight s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e
dot com promo co garbage do it skylight
so you were living it so you were living
i was living in holland pennsylvania you
were living like a normal life for a
minute i was working for my family's
company uh-huh uh
living in a townhouse with a buddy
right out of coco townhouse because you
make fun of me for that i grew up in
town line that i grew up in a townhouse
i also growing up my dad had town houses
as well we're talking like the the round
like there's encircled ones the
clubhouse the pool
all that this didn't have uh this wasn't
one of those like you ever come by like
a little townhouse strip where it's just
like a few in a row no this was a proper
development because those things are
like man how do you end up there it's on
like a boulevard or something yeah
uh no this was a proper
thing um
but the there was like a clubhouse and a
pool and whatever on the way it was big
but on the way other side i never i mean
we never [ __ ] never [ __ ] with it
sure um
but we would go to the
local bars all the time right depending
on who was working you know tammy's
working and it was always you always
fell in love with one of the
one of those [ __ ]
beer slinging tugboats that were and
like they just
they knew we've talked about this before
but they knew something about a hot
chick in an umpire's uniform yeah and
behind the bar and they used to like cut
the cleavage down and like they would
like cut the neck of the shirt down to
show the cleavage kill you digging in a
strong confident tough no shot and there
would be like [ __ ] 25 on like a
wednesday night like 25 mouth breathers
being like hey tiffany and she would
string them all along a little bit yeah
not string them along but
be nice to them yeah that's your job of
course customer service but [ __ ]
bozos they think i got a shot with her
so many of my i was never that guy to be
like i think i have a shot so many of my
friends were like uh i'm just gonna
because i'd be like we'd be all like yo
we're getting the [ __ ] out of here gonna
get something you make that move he'd be
like everything my one body would be
like i'm gonna hang out here see what
goes on and we'd be like dude what are
you doing no way is it happening
no way no
just watched you [ __ ] knock down
[ __ ] 15 beers how many chicken
fingers couple of yeagers [ __ ] darts
freak out over a monday night football
be a bad dipper
yeah dude [ __ ]
that's a tough one have a breathalyzer
in your car
meanwhile she's sober the whole time oh
that's a tough gig for those ladies man
dealing with [ __ ]
yeah beat it however that being said a
great local bartender is [ __ ]
fantastic fantastic i i i always watched
from the i never really believed i had a
show i was also a fat tubby [ __ ] for
most of this time you know what i mean
so it wasn't like i was i didn't think
like there was way i wish you knew
yourself yeah there was way more
attractive guys i wasn't gonna i knew i
wasn't gonna bring her home with that
dollar fifty tip on a bud light you know
what i mean hey tiff what are you doing
after i'm going home with lord ass at
the end of the bar
you see that balding tubby [ __ ] down
there what was that what was that polish
general uh jacket you had that was a
nice jacket oh man he used to have this
jacket dude it looked like [ __ ] that
looks like polish special forces dude do
you look like a welder right now what
are you talking about fair enough
that looks like a flak jacket
so we were talking about you what the
hell getting bamboozled over here anyway
real that was a banana republic jacket
very nice very nice probably more
expensive than anything you own i wore
it for five years after it wouldn't fit
you yeah i wore it then he took it and
you gave it to dave temple who i just
saw wearing it like two weeks no you
didn't yeah and he was like i'm
officially retiring this is the last
time i'm wearing it you can win that too
[Laughter]
giving the store away literally
if you can beat our prices we'll give
the studio away
um yeah that's a tough look you know
what's going away i still have buddies
my buddy
pat he's got some places where he's
about god remember we went out after
he's like timmy's working he's he's an
established gentleman
he's doing well he's enjoying himself
he's also in a dart league
pretty cool
[Laughter]
they can yeah you know what's going away
i've noticed in new york city used to be
so much more prevalent that made you
love bartenders the buy-back
is that a universal term the buy-back i
don't know
i think so
there's only one place that i know that
we hang that does it like the way they
used to do it old school new york where
i won't say the name of it on air
but and everybody else is going to get
[ __ ] free drinks sweet nuts no it's
not everybody what plate i don't know
what you're talking about the place that
we usually go to i this is what i'm
confused
bozo yeah we do where the comics usually
go where i go all right fine where you
going yeah dude you've been here like
three times in the past 10 years what's
a buyback
a buy back is when like um
you know you're having a few rounds uh
you're sitting there got some cash on
the table you're tipping pretty heavy
then all of a sudden the bartender comes
over and i'll put a shot glass in front
of you next one's on me yeah it's like
if you're buying do they ask or like
what they'll do is like when you go to
close out they'll be like hey that last
one was on us or whatever that that
round of shots was on me he makes a
little bit more money you feel good
you're coming back but you're also just
giving him that money like you still
have to pay for the beer sure like in
tip and then like you know yeah if
you're not getting free shots from a
bartender yeah you suck and you're not
fun especially at a place where you hang
frequently of course yeah of course i
didn't know if they still did it you
know what i mean you don't really think
customers you're probably not doing it
at applebee's or whatever but you know
because they watch when you're drinking
good in the neighborhood they're doing
it right
you know what i hate in a bar when they
have the electric pourers
wear it like i don't think i've i don't
think i've ever been to one of those
have you seen that what where you would
go to the bar in star wars where the
[ __ ] do you see that where they they
have like a little ring they put on top
of the bottle so it's an exact
measurement every time it like digitally
tracks [ __ ] yeah out of here with that
[ __ ] kick rock yeah where are you
they're super common now it sucks get
out of here not for me i don't frequent
those places
um
remember for a while we were pushing
that uh
serve your own beer remember those guys
came to us and asked us to do a show
we're gonna move on okay okay
what are you doing i just said we're
moving on
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] narc over here dude
[ __ ] kind of tapes rolling
and we're back
i said something i shouldn't
no you can leave that that's fine but
yeah i mean we're not we're not going to
marinate on that all right um this one
uh this is from from salami hussein uh
have you ever rode a bike while holding
a bike alongside you at the same time
that's cowboy [ __ ] right there
dude i'm not gonna lie though i
genuinely remember the exact place i was
the first time i saw it and i was in the
car and i look at this kid riding this
bike and i literally thought i'm like
his parents must be gone or something
they're not around nobody does that what
happened to the other kid where's the
bike something bad has happened yeah
something bad has happened or was stolen
that's typically it yeah yeah can you do
that i've never done it no i don't think
i'm bad on bikes
oh yeah i
forgot i wasn't talking to lance
armstrong over here
uh i always assume it's a dead giveaway
to the bike stolen when it's all wrapped
up in black tape
when they wrap the entire bike in black
tape
no the all the delivery drivers do that
why so it doesn't chip the paint on the
bike and you can probably like resell it
and stuff
huh if you ever notice it's really where
it's like it's like foam tape kind of
yeah yeah that's so it's like the metal
lock doesn't [ __ ] destroy the bike
because a lot of times either those
bikes are rented or [ __ ] whatever
really yeah yeah very nice you learned
something look at that educational
podcast i like that you should know and
you have talked to enough delivery
drivers that you should have uh
yeah we talk about other things
very trashy yes
this one i never thought of this is from
chris scott is calling aluminum foil
tinfoil garbage
well if it is i'm trying i say tin foil
i still say tin foil tin foil all the
way
or right i would say rental drap
no that's the plastic stuff
but reynolds is the brand reynolds is
the brand we're always reynolds down the
line yeah yeah unless it's like really
in a pinch but like if they're out of it
but it's reynolds has that [ __ ] wrap
it in tin foil yeah we don't say
aluminum foil aluminium yeah we're not
scientists how the british say it
aluminium what yeah
[ __ ] idiot i didn't know my wife said
it and i was like what because she
learned it when she was in say it again
aluminium sounds like a fake name from
the simpsons
yeah called moe's barwin yeah
that's whack is aluminium there we have
an aluminium hey son of a [ __ ] um
yeah
tinfoil foil but did it used to be tin
is it a tin now
no i would assume it's aluminum oh yeah
um
man was it can we get some info on this
tip tin versus if it was tin foil that
must have been sturdy
you wouldn't be able to get yourself tin
knockers wrapping up the fire you would
be able to get your sandwich out of
there yeah got those hot bolts in it
hot bolts
like they do when they're building
buildings they throw the hot bolts in
there rivets yeah rivets um
it started out as 10 uh that's insane it
seems so expensive
yeah it's what was it actually a
thousand dollars much more expensive and
less durable compared to aluminum foil
but they stopped doing it in the 1910s
but the name tinfoil is still widely
used
it must have been brutal to use so i
don't know anybody who's ever used
tinfoil but we still call it tinfoil
tinfoil if they stopped in 1910
man that's real trash that's that's how
you know your family is generational
garbage this is so gross too tin foils
are actually stiffer than aluminum foil
and can leave a bitter taste to food
wrapped in it oh
my blood just went cold dude that's no
good
it must have been a tough look back then
this one this isn't the same anything
sorry anything before the 60s it must be
refrigeration was has
hairy to say the to say
to say the least dude it was dicey
imagine how warm a refrigerator was in
the 1950s oh dude no imagine foley
operating in a world without air
conditioning oh or a hot shower you'd be
forced to lose weight for the a-team
[ __ ] losing
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that man
no bueno
i would have signed up for world war one
you would have would have yeah
get it over with
you shoot yourself in the parking lot
all right uh yeah sold your fault
i unless you're brutal yeah um this
one's in the same this room this isn't
even a question this is from jt
hernandez i used to take sandwiches
wrapped in newspaper to school as a kid
that is a tough that's got to be in the
40s how old are you are you a private
eye what the [ __ ] yeah i don't insane
you got a [ __ ] article on the white
bread when you get there you rolled the
dice rap in your books in [ __ ]
newspaper like that never newspaper
brown paper background paperback rolled
the dice my dad could put a seal on a
brown paper bag like you wouldn't
believe dude that thing that was water
oh dude his ocd would really kick in
around book wrap and talk
dude newspaper on a double that's
there's you're getting ink on that
that's what i'm saying the funnies are
going to be on your roll
you got marbaduke on a bb and j
silly putty sandwich over here the [ __ ]
out of here yeah
oh man
moms and parents open it up it's wrapped
in a cow door
[ __ ]
flyer
moms and parents didn't care didn't know
how big those things impacted kids also
your confidence yeah you're standing
within the lunchroom sure
i thought about this a lot recently
even from like
when i when we were kids to things now
that like
things that my family would never even
look at because you're like that like
new
technology like there's even like the
zip locks or the whatever
you like the kids go to school now they
got it's well that's what i'm saying
it's all things are now so much cheaper
and more
standard success okay that's what i'm
saying like back in the 80s and 90s like
that [ __ ] wasn't
dude remember the [ __ ] big
gallon or like you know the big ziplock
bags that had the [ __ ] slider on it
that might as well have been like
[ __ ] 50 bucks a clip to us like sure
that's what we had to roll over john's
that well now it's like if
nobody has that anymore and i think back
then like
you seem said have a sandwich wrapped in
newspaper and if somebody was in a bag
you were like yeah a fresh sandwich and
those rollovers though they were pretty
nice i never i didn't even they never
[ __ ]
picture two pieces of mares potato bread
slice of american cheese and a couple
slices of salami with a little french's
mustard
and it would sit so long that the
mustard would kind of soak through the
middle of the bread oh
fantastic it's [ __ ] gross
how is that gross i don't know you're
dreaming about a sandwich you had
[ __ ] 35 years i wasn't dreaming about
it you made me
feel fantasized yeah whatever
daydreaming
um
all right this one's from thick
i don't know something thick is there a
door to your house that no one has a key
for and then parentheses said new homie
which i like i love it yeah that's a
ghoul uh
any doors that you can't open no but
they always frighten me at people's
houses what oh you can't go that way
can't go that way we have we had when we
just boarded it up
it's in it's actually in the
it's in the opening of the youtube video
we're in the in the garage
okay if you look behind me when i'm
lighting my sig oh that's in the garage
yeah i just said it's in the garage oh
okay i know exactly yeah there was a
door there so we they put it in after
the fact so you
could get in the garage without having
to open the garage door i don't know why
but they i was back before there was an
opener so i guess like my mom would have
trouble it was like that big metal
[ __ ] door
you know so
now when you say they boarded it up
because i gotta let you know that's not
a great statement no they they
removed
listen there's there's open drywall at
your parents house right now not anymore
yeah just got read that that adjuster
finally showed up
um i got him to play ball
they uh no that boarded up they removed
the door and whatever and the outside's
finished but the inside as you can see
in the opening of the youtube video
is
still
open drywall like it's like plywood and
drywall but the door's gone yeah i just
said they've removed the door yeah yeah
but that because for 25 years no one had
the key
or third however long it was just
[ __ ]
you couldn't get in there yeah that's
no one knew who had the key that's
haunted how [ __ ] to me i don't like that
at all yeah
one way in one way out just how i like
it i remember my one buddy's house he
had an older house
and there was a
you'd go upstairs and it'd be normal
bedrooms but then there was like um like
an old office door that had like the
huge window pane in it say that again
i'm sorry oh inside the inside now that
like went to a room it was like an
exterior door
yeah inside yeah that's always that led
to steps that went nowhere
never slept over that kid's house yeah i
was out of there before the sun went
down
we had um
so growing up on my block so like where
they uh
in my area like in bucks county that was
all farmland in like the 60s 70s 80s
and into the same thing with monco and
they started developing that as people
were leaving the city and so like every
neighborhood
has the farmhouse in it where the farmer
sold the land to develop the land and
still yeah most of the deals were like
hey i'll sell the land but like i'm
keeping my house
the original guy who sold the land yeah
so a lot of the neighborhoods have the
farmhouse in it like because the deal
was like hey i'll sell you the land but
i'm keeping this this plot
and the farmhouse is on my
block like like on my street it's a
couple houses down for me that's it i
didn't see it if they did it it's like
looks nice stuff now but the fact that's
that farmer's name
oh i don't know yeah i mean i had a
[ __ ] no idea i was [ __ ] four when
they bought the house
um but the family that lived there
bought it like somebody bought that
house instead of buying one of the new
construction houses bought the farmhouse
oh man and this family was bonkers dude
you gotta be dude you would walk into
that they had like multiple addicts that
were like you couldn't get to because it
was a proper farmhouse from like the
[ __ ] 1800s
man and you would walk into the summer
we used to run around and those doors it
had the metal keys like the
like the old jail cell keys to open the
doors haunted mansion yes [ __ ] that and
you would open the door and a chill
would just hit your back
some [ __ ] spirit was lurking
heavy bike dude
some farm hand who got murdered in there
yeah yeah nope yeah it was [ __ ] and
running around that i remember just i
know that feeling you feel like the
air's on but it's not and it's your
smells diff you walk in your that's a
ghost man yeah whatever the [ __ ] at it
uh-huh gang let's talk about helix helix
you know it helix mattress
been been been with us since jump street
i like family literally like family
kippy's been going night night on the
helix for a long time absolutely
fantastic you don't want to be walking
on a mattress store these days and after
time the salesman's throwing jargon at
that you don't know cut all that stuff
out go to helix.com take the quiz find
out how you sleep let them know they'll
set you up whether you sleep light sleep
heavy sleep hot sleep cold and if you're
a bigger guy like me they have plus size
matches yeah you don't wanna you won't
be walking around a macho store like a
bazzo bozo uh
like we've said the good folks at helix
were nice enough to send me and me and
my old lady uh a mattress we took the
quiz two minutes
boom she took it not me she gets to say
we got the twilight but i i love it it's
fantastic my first like nice adult
mattress it's very impressive i'm very
jealous if you're in if you're in the
market for it get one a lot of our
listeners are getting them and loving it
um they were picked overall best match
number one best mattress overall by 2020
by gq and wired magazine
um it's
recommended by multiple leading
chiropractors and doctors of sleep
medicine
come on what are we doing improve your
sleep let's go to helix.com
helix sleep.com garbage take the two
minute quiz helix leaf is all helix
sleep is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time
sleep.com garbage up to 200 off all
mattress orders do free pillows do it
gang let's talk about express vpn the
best in the biz everybody's stealing
from me these days okay everybody's got
their hands in their pockets everybody
does you have to get a vpn express is
the best you got to get on top of it
protect yourself and your online
presence yeah uh every time you're
connected to expressvpn you'll get a
random ip address shared by many other
expressvpn customers that makes it
harder for third per third parties to
identify and harvest your data
everybody's looking where you're at
they're selling it expressvpn keeps you
protected so not everybody's using using
all your info and selling it and hey
listen if you want to sell it you sell
it you make a couple of bucks right
don't be letting these bozos running
around the internet stealing stealing
your phone selling it you don't even get
to wet your beak
um but if you so if you really want to
go incognito mode and protect your
privacy secure yourself with the number
one number one rated vpn visit
expressvpn.com garbage and get three
extra months for free one more time
that's three extra months for free at
expressvpn.com expressvpn.com
garbage
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n svpn.com
garbage go to expressvpn.com to learn
more now back
i'm not doing that but it was all those
doors that were like oh we don't go to
that side of the house and i'm like what
the [ __ ] is happening here dude natural
trash like terror within the walls you
know what else is really trashy being at
somebody's house and knowing that the
pool was filled in
do you ever have that yeah there used to
be a pool back there but they filled it
in building a pool is always a bad luck
we talked about it on the patreon
episode with pat they filled it they
sold their old house they filled this
room and they just threw all their trash
there's like bikes
skeeves you out um
all right this one's from george uh
first time long time i love how they're
doing that it's so [ __ ] uh
you know sports radio trash uh love it
have you ever played a scratch off at
the counter after buying it which is the
toughest of the looks if you're
scratching it in the store
be a gentleman go outside sit in the car
do it there not as you're throwing a
hail mary i get it i saw a dude the
other day
i saw a dude the other day he was
[ __ ] he had just done he just got
done digging ditches or painting or
something like that definitely blue
collar definitely had a long hard day he
had one of the big jaws like the 30
dollar one and he was right there in
line
just trying to crawl out of work hold on
i'm gonna get a 32 and a 14 and then
three number ones or whatever but just
think every once in a while some guy
does that says i'm [ __ ] quitting and
they win and they [ __ ] quit yeah they
get to [ __ ] sleep in i saw a guy in a
7-eleven buy a 40 lottery ticket scratch
it off the line and then just go [ __ ]
i only have
plan a yeah
god damn it i cashed it all in on this
letting it ride
on rich for life
[Laughter]
i i have a suspicion about the lottery
too oh here we go
more people could win and they could
still make enough money what
of course
smaller jackpots more winners
that's the answer
nobody needs [ __ ] this is your
mayoral platform yeah what you're
talking about the answer for who the
scratcher it would be better it would be
a better society kevin okay that's what
we're trying to build here
you think the scratch-off world is a
microcosm for society i think the
scratch-off world is a microcosm for
society and a lot of hard-working people
play the lottery sure okay the problem
is they stacked these big [ __ ]
um
uh what are they called jackpots okay
like what was the last huge one it was
in the basement it's not scratchers
though so right now you don't know what
you're talking about they're not scratch
off lottery tickets i'm just saying the
lottery in general you said so you
started with strategies just go with you
want to be my [ __ ] campaign manager
no i don't because you're a bozo and you
don't stand a chance at the polls t-bone
you're my running mate yeah good luck
d-bone
you could do it or you're 5 000 steps a
day you could do it come on nothing on
that there should be more winners
they can afford to do more winners
whether it's scratch-offs with the
regular lottery lower the jackpot and
spread it around a little bit
just put it around but that doesn't
excite anybody sure it does no it
doesn't who wants you want the [ __ ]
juicy jackpot
you could still have a jew you don't
need
the last one was like 20 billion dollars
wasn't it
no it's not 20 billion dollars what was
it it was in the billions yeah i think
it was like one billion yeah there you
go bill that's a big difference in 20
billion so you could slice that down to
500 to 500 million and let two people
win
or or chop that down 20 30 40 50 grand
50 grand why not getting anybody out of
bed in the morning for fifth juice has
to be worth the squeeze i guarantee the
guy at 7-eleven would have [ __ ]
settled for 50 g odds wouldn't he have
told he's in it for the he's in it for
the [ __ ] one billy no one plays the
lottery being like let me win 700 you
want it all that's why you're playing
that's why you lose dancing with your
bet the smart money
back to smart money
that's not fun i always wanted to do
that daily number pick five no that's
for losers what yeah
crazy playing those regular numbers kick
rocks
i'm in it for the big mamajamas like the
action huh yeah what are we doing here i
can make 700 bucks somewhere i can't
make a billion
also that windfall in a day what are we
doing
imagine waking up and realize you got a
billy oh my god i'm collecting that
check wearing chain mail in a face mask
yeah i'd send someone to collect it for
me oh 100
if i ever won the lottery not a chance
in hell i'm going public at that that's
the last thing i want people to know
you're right dude i wouldn't go public
with it you don't want to be the [ __ ]
lottery guy you're nuts you do you
wouldn't be able to hide it i know you
wouldn't
just walking around smiling all day yeah
wearing a suit made out of thousand
dollar bills yeah
i mean the second you buy a new t-shirt
people are like something's up here
this guy came across a little bit of
cash
got the key to one of them doors that
won't open
[Laughter]
uh all right this one's from boner
mcasshole
that's a good piece of business
i think you just got yourself a palm
tree teacher uh
is it garbage to officiate your sister's
second wedding
bad look i wonder who did the first
it couldn't have been him right i didn't
bring him back in for the second one
yeah you don't bring him you got the
heebie-jeebies you get married twice
would you do the same priest do you get
to say you're the same person i think
you do a different state different
country you can't that one's you i wear
black
make everybody come upside down yeah i i
believe in june
i believe in superstitions a little bit
yeah it's like it's also more of just
like okay that one didn't work
i'm not going you know doing the same
thing over you're going to get the same
result no that's jeans and folding
chairs in there yeah that's real like
hey we're going to jamaica whoever wants
to come come i want to say this
this might be a slightly unpopular
opinion it might rub some people the
wrong way even some people close to us
but i'm going to say it anyway
i think
the look of having your friend
officiated
is kind of whack
i understand what you're saying usually
stink i understand what you're saying as
someone who's done it
it is case in point no uh
it is a very
cool moment if you're like proper
friends with them it it is a very
and by the way i killed it is a very uh
murdered
anybody here from the groom's side
how about the bride's side
[Laughter]
i plugged the patreon at the end of it
you know uh then i said ring bear
and we're
back um
i it is a very
uh
nice moment to have someone be a part of
that because if for people who aren't
very religious
right like if you're religious it means
something to you to have
the priest there or like you're [ __ ]
the clergy or the whatever not a big fan
of that either i don't like i don't like
some bozo that doesn't know the person
doing the funeral whether it's a priest
or not and they throw in a couple of
[ __ ] things yeah yeah he lived like
oh yeah i had someone i heard he was a
big filly's fan dude i had some [ __ ] i
had someone die in like my extended
family who
was hated by everyone and hated everyone
like
the family members she was a loving
woman dude family members didn't show up
kids it was like a it was a scene and
the priest is sitting there like well
you know everybody knows he really loved
his family and like there was like a
gasp as he said i'm like do you know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
i don't like that either so
i would like to retract my statement i
guess it is nice but a lot of times it
is it looks
if they're a bozo the whole thing
becomes a bozo show
you're really going to take it seriously
do it good
yeah i think that's obviously the plan i
think sometimes it's executed
poorly yeah right by the person but
long-winded to crying the inappropriate
jokes did you make anything you go
delilah's what are you talking about
inappropriate jokes uh
made a couple who'd you marry phil and
lauren you did i did you married them
huh now what's something like that
what'd it go for
nothing come to thinking nothing he is a
20
20 card carrying patreon member though
since the inception excellent so it's
paid off there you go um
i made a couple of jokes because i i've
known her for a long time i became
really good friends with him as well
separately
and so like i did uh i actually had my
my wife helped me write it i'm like oh
this is there and like i did like a
ghost writer huh i did a long thing on
her i'm like yeah she's great blah blah
blah and i go and phil
i don't know much about him or whatever
i'm like that got a big laugh i'm like
seems like a cool guy big laugh but kept
it short sweet
uh and then my closer i thought was
pretty good i was like my closer by the
power invested me by the good people at
www.universal
church
i now pronounce you i remember didn't i
punch this up a little bit i don't think
so i think i might have had a writing
credit or two in there
and i believe i don't recall is that was
that not the first time that the
the toast was used no that was for my
brother ah you his wedding i didn't
officiate his wedding i was the best man
at his wedding and he used the toast
yes
wait down that royalty check huh
had a bunch of people hitting me up for
that sure
everybody gets it uh-huh everybody gets
it hit me up i gotcha yeah it's a
[ __ ] that and a t-shirt buy one get
one tell me that things tell me that
thing's not a [ __ ] that's not
bulletproof i've said it's really good i
had to do some [ __ ] audibles and some
changes you know you got a little
[ __ ] artsy fartsy with it at a
[ __ ] steam fitter's wedding the house
of the rising sun doesn't really go over
so well all right
well you got a little you were in your
little [ __ ] poet your little
shakespeare bag okay we're living in
reality these are dirt balls without a
goddamn future okay
they don't know what thy is yeah
thus as i settled my head down like
jesus christ you [ __ ] artsy dork i
bet you do have a shakespeare monologue
in the chamber at all times how all
occasions do inform against me and spur
my adult revenge what is the man if the
chief good in the market of his time you
but feeding sleep a beast no more and
surely he is the greatest just
it's about food you're stepping on my
shakespeare oh i'm sorry this [ __ ]
guy
walk out of here right now go ahead i
apologize no you think i'm going back
into it
that was mid-rift that was [ __ ]
hamlet god damn it i'm trying to class
this place up of course it's about ham
again
and we're back
that's how a pro does it
if you ever see a hamlet on the menu in
a deli get it it's fantastic
yo they're doing honey baked hamlet in
the park this weekend
foley's headlining
but yes toby i am trained i'm a
classically trained actor
i've read the greats
some of them i tell people i read a lot
more than i did on me sure
this is from jake smith i don't know if
this has ever been touched i'll never
had a question asked did you have a
garbage disposal in your house growing
up we've talked about this many times
man i don't many i would say it's been
discussed we also discussed the trash
compactor
yeah we all center of course trash
compactor we also discussed the early
days of the water purification system
that people would put on their
uh faucets i understand that which is
trash sure the garbage disposal
is it garbage or not
the garbage disposal is not garbage the
garbage disposal is classy use not
having one use proper not having one
it's trashy i don't know about you oh
see okay you're in your bag what do you
got here did you have one growing up i
did not here we go no
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry i
apologize we had it in the townhouse
because it was newer construction
but our house you have one now no we
don't have that
here we go this is the agent you would
have to get that added on you can't get
those added on without doing a whole
re-pipe job welcome to the h foley spin
zone do you have one yeah of course i
have one that goes
yeah we just spend money and flex on the
neighbors we put a door and then never
over they can get a smell they can kick
it a little bit
you know what so can just [ __ ] food
scraps in the trash can
that's why i take the trash out oh
really i just saw you throw trash on the
ground fair enough
no yeah fair enough uh they're classy
it's the it's the civilized way to
discard of your food waste to say
anything else is bonkers where does it
go plus there's some videos where a
stepmom gets her hand stuck
looking for a wedding ring and then an
unsuspecting stepson arrives it's a nice
layer and he yanks from yeah um
so
yeah no it's the civilized way where
does the food go it [ __ ] chops it up
into a bunch of [ __ ] pieces uh-huh
and then i guess like through the
[ __ ] waste pipe
really yeah the poop pipe
yeah yeah
interesting so i mean if your [ __ ]
turds can fit in there so can you know
regular you can get a garbage disposal
installed in your [ __ ] i had that
question you ever clogged a toilet just
with poop
not with toilet paper i've never i don't
think i've ever properly i don't think
i've ever clogged a toilet really ever
wow look at you ever [ __ ] rabbit
poops over here it's like a deer
a tight little bun on this kid
i never have i don't know if there was
any concern
of it
oh i have over toilet paper that's what
i'm saying i would give a courtesy flush
to be like okay i'm not gonna clog this
thing
it's a go-getter i mean
it's just logic to me
toby you backed up to [ __ ] once or
twice
[ __ ] redneck
those north carolina [ __ ] pipes
god damn it toby backed up the shooter
again
[Laughter]
oh this is one was there a growing up
how far was the walk to the outhouse
was there a bathroom in smoky mountains
was there a bathroom in any of your
houses that you couldn't poop in
what yeah my friend had one on the first
floor like don't poop in that one for
some reason i don't know why i guess
not great plumbing i presume
uh no but i do remember as a kid are you
friends with howie mandel that's [ __ ]
weird that doesn't make any sense
germaphobe what cut it move go as a kid
when your parents were out when your
parents were out of the house you were
alone i used to like pooping in the
different bathrooms that weren't like
allotted to me you know
oh taking a nice dump in some kid's
parents master bathroom when they're not
around
ah it's like being in a hotel
[ __ ] fantastic wiping with the towels
and [ __ ]
hey room service couple more towels up
here please
it shows that they had a phone next to
it next to the can i had one guy had
that that was like they thought that was
cool in the 90s for like a week yeah it
never really that was for businessmen in
the 90s yeah that never really there was
like some hotels that would have that
type thing but i never made sense to me
like what can't wait [ __ ] six minutes
no we always only ever had one or two
bathrooms it was it was [ __ ] where you
can
yeah you're a two bathroom house i'm a
two birth two bathroom family yeah we're
we're one and a half right now that's
what we got now one and a half oh that
downstairs isn't full no well he's
[ __ ] taking a shower in the basement
what are we fishermen it's technically
not a basement yeah it is that's a
basement that walks outside yeah it's
california split level move on toby cut
that
mom california's white trash that's what
it really is
anyway uh yeah no one bathroom one
bathroom no garbage disposal so garbage
okay but back to that garbage disposals
are classy for sure okay it's the it's
the civilized way to discard of your
waste and for you to say otherwise
shows you're an [ __ ] fair enough
um this one's from luke coffey ever buy
a trash can for your car
that is a tough look that's but so we've
talked about this but so is the [ __ ]
bag over the shifter
that's a tough look too of course but
they're the same thing to me the fact
that you're accumulating trash in your
car and not disposing of it immediately
is a bad look true that's the
i mean it's your car it's not the
kitchen and you know what i mean there's
whatever you're consuming in your car
should be
you go into 7-eleven get a plastic bag
with water and chips or soda and chips
walk out consume that put it back in the
bag throw it out on the way out that's
how trash should be operated in a car by
the way i've been shot down for loans
before this is the longest that it's
gone
where
i would i feel like i would have been
shot down by now
uh this is from ryan cosman first time
heating up cold brew coffee in the
microwave because my coffee maker's
broken clean living or garbagio
i don't understand it fully i assume
he's buying cold brew like those like
individual cold brew things
pouring it into a cup and microwaving
that oh
god damn that's disgusting or he's
making cold brew and then heating it up
or he's letting coffee from yesterday in
the fridge yeah and then reheating it up
either way but he can't he can't make
coffee that's what i'm saying he said
his coffee maker is broken so he can't
make coffee so he either has to cold
brew it himself why would he buy a hot
coffee
i don't know buddy i'm saying go to
[ __ ] starbucks hit a donkey's
you know go to a bodega get a cup of
coffee what are we doing here i have put
cold brew i have put an iced coffee in
the fridge overnight and drank it the
next day yeah i don't we've talked about
this i don't like doing that at all that
is not my [ __ ] cup of tea you know
what's a tough look is ice in a beverage
in the refrigerator you can't if there's
melts a little bit yeah you can't do
that just like there's a clear level
floating at the top you get that you got
to give that a little shaky shake no
it's never the same i would just my head
i'm like i'll just go get another
whatever the [ __ ] that is yeah it's
trash man yeah it's garbage uh all right
this one's from orlando alvarez haven't
had a question read yet always hearing
the pool question was it garbage for
your dad who makes in-ground pools for a
living but never have one at home so
instead he buys an above-ground pool
every summer what that is every summer i
guess he gets those like disposable
jaundice oh mike will you see the fat
lady slicing it open at the end of the
year and that dumb broad gets taken out
every single time too
one of those yeah those things are
trapped yeah well it's i guess it's like
to the point like the price point of
like all right well it was like 300
bucks or whatever we're not gonna save
it we'll just get a [ __ ] new one they
have like filters and pumps on them too
yes obviously some are better than
others and you know size is dependent
upon it and stuff wow but a [ __ ] you
figure a guy that was that
worked for a company that could
that did in ground pools could afford it
in ground pool he's probably i mean he's
probably manual labor he's you know what
i mean i don't know if he oh the owner
of an in-ground pool i assume there's
some friends and family pricing i would
assume so to get a little [ __ ] ten
percent off of his promo code garbage or
something man you know what i mean tough
luck yeah
that's right that's trash yeah bad luck
uh those videos are great you see a
little 10 year old going into a fence
line ah the best man there's so much
water in there the dog rips it off or
something
that's great
so good
well also you see some people neighbors
are always around and might i add never
a fence around those pools no those are
they didn't pull permits for that now um
it's always trashy too like some people
that's how people some people dispose of
them the proper way would be the hose
like out to the [ __ ] sewer or
whatever yeah and pump it out but these
[ __ ] hillbillies are just [ __ ]
slicing it open i was a neighbor i'd be
[ __ ] pissed soaks the whole [ __ ]
yard the whole side of the [ __ ] block
get your foundation yeah
that ain't [ __ ] good now
that's what happened to the basement
it's not flooded oh yeah shout out to
toddy
um also i want to say on in regards to
that i forgot to say at the beginning i
had a buddy who
family did like adjusting and it was
always real like hey we got this new
couch type thing they're like yeah it
was damaged and i'm like oh you guys are
playing it real fast and loose with this
damage business
like oh we got a new pinball machine the
first one of everything is damaged yeah
it's that oh this is down you see the
bottom yeah there's like i'm like a
little [ __ ] touch-up
but now it's at your house you're
[ __ ] dicing you're not gonna go to
the mattresses for it yeah and they're
like wow it's a win-win they're getting
mom i'm like all right keep me [ __ ]
out of this i like a win-win
that was always you get calls like hey
does anybody in your family need a love
seat you're like dude what are we doing
just [ __ ] trash it or like come on
was one of the cushions missing yeah
um we did we were big on that what
things circulated around our network of
family and friends
like um
somebody would have like patio furniture
they would get new patio furniture my
mom would take that patio furniture we
still have the patio footage that's in
our sun room right now is from one of
our cousins
who who had who they had moved and they
didn't need it yeah it's also like i
guess if it has some life left in it
yeah sure yeah i had a sectional in my
apartment in philly which was a product
of divorce i had sex in my apartment in
philly too did you not bad quit bragging
um
yeah we always did that [ __ ] it was
always like age like the college kids
age
like a cousin would be moving and be
like hey do you need this
and then like you always felt like
obligated to be like yeah i guess type
thing and you're like well now i have
like [ __ ] you know i have four love
seats and not a real size couch
yeah i always thought there should be an
irish guy who sold outdoor furniture and
he would call it patio furniture oh this
is patio's furniture
welcome to patio furniture
for all your outdoor needs
welcome to patios
it has to be out there
um all right let's do one more then wrap
it up this one's from timbo slice still
haven't had a question asked will you
will you fart at a urinal in a crowded
bathroom
no
i don't have the confidence for that no
i don't either
t-bone
i really try not to yeah it's tough i
try sometimes if you you let us squeak
if i know it's not going to be
a scene
sure
if i think it's going to be a little you
know sbd type thing old school dudes do
it i think it's a reflex for older guys
just like
like they can't you know yeah i'm
surprised you you have control like that
yeah i just i would just feel terrible
yeah
plus i don't need them peeking over to
see what the merchandise is like
i try not to draw too much attention to
myself when i'm in there you're sitting
on the counter peeing out
sbd shitty backdoor silent but deadly ah
you've never heard sbb holy holy [ __ ]
oh are you god homeschooling there would
you say shitty backdoor well that was a
joke but uh
no of course i heard silent but deadly
it just didn't connect to my brain wow
this guy's a real [ __ ] bozo no i
can't do it timbo says this is how i
establish dominance
a lot of guys do that which i understand
you go ahead i'm the king of this castle
the guy
yeah
guy seldom washes his hands yeah
i'm gonna go on record i never wash my
hands out of the bathroom really i poop
yeah p no stop at a rest stop i'm not
washing my hands in a [ __ ] public
bathroom are you hitting this hand
sanitizer yeah now especially the
sanitizer everywhere but it's like yeah
you wash your hands and then you hit
like a door whatever nah [ __ ] that yeah
you see me washing my hands i'm doing it
for you benefit 100 all right let's wrap
her up what a fun episode what a great
family episode we love you guys uh
tickets are on sale for hartford for
albany for syracuse yes sir get those
techies last shows of the year get those
ticked we love you guys we'll see you
next week
peace